i want to talk to you about wander
darkly i had the chance to
uh talk to diego luna about the film i
got to see the film
and your performance is so wrenching
this is i i can't imagine what you went
through to
have to play this part because it is
such a demanding role
it is such an incredibly demanding role
it's it
i don't want to try and sum up the movie
but it's a very intense story about a
couple and they go through
trauma and then it's trying to figure
out which reality is the correct reality
and it's beautifully done and
beautifully acted but
i felt i don't know how you survived
every day of
filming that movie because it felt like
you had to be wrung out
at the end of every day yes that might
be the understatement of the year it was
so tiring it was just it was but there's
really weirdly catharsis in that kind of
work
i don't know it's strange but yes it was
hard it was hard and it was confusing
and disorienting and
all of those things but we didn't know
that we were we had no
idea how it was going to come together
and i think they did a really beautiful
job with all the effects and
you know it's surreal i think you summed
it up very well as a story because it's
very hard for me to ever describe what
it's about but
with sort of a life-affirming loving
feeling at the end
even if you've been through something
yeah you you bet you definitely uh
you you go through a lot you watch this
couple go through a lot but
i was talking to diego and diego uh
obviously gives a
a a terrific performance but i felt your
character had to
you just had to really put it all out
there in a way that
i i can't not being an actor i can't
even imagine
what that's like but um it's a
it's a really terrific performance thank
you conan
i think i've explored grief now at this
point i don't know that i've got any
more
to show from that perspective i think
i'm ready for some tap dancing
reality hair cutting
[Laughter]
it's done it's done i would imagine we
have a clip we're going to show now from
wander darkly
uh which in which i think it's actually
a very good clip
to show in this moment because it
encapsulates the extremes
that your character is driven to in this
film and again uh
this just gives you a taste of some of
the intensity of the movie
and it's just like i say the tip of the
iceberg yeah
so let's show this clip right now from
wonder darkly
[Applause]
you weren't there with ellie where do
you go
what happens to you you just you get
scared and then what you just
you disappear you concussed that's it
yeah i'm dead if i can step into traffic
now it wouldn't matter
hey hey
[Applause]
it's okay what is this like purgatory
what's happening to me just hold on to
me
well are you able to film now in
london are you able to work now during
the pandemic i'm
shooting which is astounding and we have
not shut down and i've been at it from
the beginning of november and it's
surreal
i mean everybody's in masks and goggles
and like i don't know what anybody looks
like and i
you know like to kind of hug people
that's not happening
but we are managing to make this show
which is
which is great tiring and this is uh
and i'm just we are doing the same thing
which is we're
we have been making shows wearing masks
getting tested
and um we're starting to get used to it
even though it's been months and months
but uh really looking forward to this
being over
me too me too although i've had many
people tell me
they uh even when this is over they
don't want me to hug them
so yeah yeah apparently that was
probably that was an issue with me
um well it's it's just delightful to
talk to you it really is
and uh i want to make sure i mentioned
because it's a terrific film wander
darkly
is now on demand on apple tv prime video
or wherever
you get your movies